[Música]
aquí comienza el debate de france 24 mi
nombre es ángela gómez y los acompaño en
este programa para analizar desde puntos
de vista opuestos el primer meses del
presidente de colombia a gustavo petro
en el cargo lejos de hacer una
evaluación pronta de su gobierno que
apenas comienza queremos entender la
ruta que asume su administración y las
perspectivas de que esto trae al país
latinoamericano para ello nos acompañan
maría josé pizarro quien es el
congresista a senadora electa por el
pacto histórico y también ricardo ferro
ex representante de la cámara por el
partido centro democrático a ambos
gracias a nuestros televidentes y
también les recuerdo que ustedes hacen
parte de esta conversación dejen sus
preguntas y comentarios en nuestras
redes sociales estamos en twitter
instagram y facebook en donde no se
encuentran con france24 guión bajo ese y
ángel ago efe 24 mi cuenta personal la
etiqueta es el numeral el debate df 24
en youtube pueden seguir nuestra señal
en streaming y también saludamos a
nuestras personas que nos escuchan en el
podcast y no olviden que todos los
contenidos d programa están disponibles
en app el podcast spotify deezer junin y
para dar inicio vamos a escuchar las
últimas declaraciones del mandatario
sobre las fronteras con venezuela que
será nuestro primer tema
el próximo 26 de septiembre daremos
apertura a la frontera entre colombia y
venezuela como primer paso se reanudará
la conexión aérea y el transporte de
carga entre nuestros países confirmamos
el compromiso del gobierno por
restablecer las relaciones de hermandad
una de las características de este
gobierno que inicia es la actitud de
gustavo petro y su intenciones de una
retoma completa de las relaciones con
venezuela que han estado paralizadas por
años una reapertura sobre la cual le
quisiera preguntarles a nuestros
invitados como la evalúan teniendo en
cuenta pues la gran importancia para las
poblaciones de que exista una relación
sana no solamente en lo económico sino
en lo político el 26 de septiembre como
lo anunciaron ambos mandatarios en
twitter sería la fecha en la que se
reabren estos puntos fronterizos después
de siete años cerrados maría josé
pizarro empiezo con ustedes sobre la
posición del gobierno de la importancia
y de cómo evalúa que se reabran estas
fronteras
pues bueno primero nosotros tenemos una
frontera con venezuela que haciendo el
símil en europa por ejemplo sería la
longitud entre madrid y berlín quiere
decir una frontera muy larga y nora más
larga que tenemos con cualquier otro
país hermano latinoamericano
estamos viviendo una situación muy
compleja y la hemos venido viviendo
durante los últimos años
precisamente por el tema migratorio que
es un tema frente al cual colombia no
estaba preparado colombia no es un país
que esté listo para recibir grandes
poblaciones de migrantes para ser un
país de tránsito
colombia es un país que al contrario es
un país que no ha sido de fronteras
sabía y por lo tanto esto ha supuesto
para nosotros en términos de la
población venezolana que vive en nuestro
país pero por supuesto también de la
población colombiana que vive en
venezuela y que además venezuela en
algún momento recibió muchísimos
colombianos y colombianas que estaban
huyendo en el marco del conflicto pero
nosotros tenemos hoy una población
inmersa inmersa en una situación real
de desprotección absoluta
de miseria en muchísimos casos somos un
país de tránsito y por lo tanto lo que
nos acongoja colombia le sucede a otros
países de américa latina y por lo tanto
es no solamente en términos comerciales
sino también en términos de poder
restablecer esas las relaciones humanas
absolutamente imperativo la apertura de
fronteras con venezuela restablecer
relaciones de relaciones diplomáticos
que realmente desde colombia se pueda
atender a la población colombiana en
venezuela pero que por supuesto en
colombia también
el gobierno venezolano puede atender a
la población venezolana que está en
colombia es decir son muchísimos los
temas
precisamente por esta situación
migratoria
precisamente porque somos países
hermanos y compartimos realidades
precisamente por la miseria que viven
millones de venezolanos que tienen que
atravesar en condiciones muy adversas y
que están a merced de todo tipo de
mafias en los puntos fronterizos y
legales que hoy pues por sue nomás eso
ya le quita un negocio que habían
establecido de manera dramática quienes
controlan esos pasos fronterizos
entonces por supuesto que no solamente
es bienvenida sino que el país estaba
realmente esperando un restablecimiento
de relaciones diplomáticas sin duda
maria jose pero si cambia mucho la
postura frente a lo que había sucedido
en el gobierno anterior y por qué no
decirlo en los gobiernos anteriores
ricardo ferro cuál es su opinión sobre
este cambio de enfoque ahora con un
gobierno de izquierda que decide
reconocer a nicolás maduro
como se venía haciendo con el gobierno
de bandos
este es el tema de fondo angela que
nosotros aquí en colombia hemos venido
atendiendo a los hermanos venezolanos
con una serie de disposiciones que sean
que han sido expedidas por el gobierno
colombiano para poder garantizar la
salud de los venezolanos que se
incorporen a la vida civil en nuestro
país que tengan derechos prerrogativas
que tiene la población colombiana de
notar que son más de dos millones de
venezolanos que han huido del régimen de
nicolás maduro y que hoy en día están en
nuestro país pero el tema de fondo es
ese hasta qué punto es
reconocer un dictador como nicolás
maduro le puede salir bien a gustavo
petro en este momento gustavo petro como
presidente de colombia quiere
restablecer lo está restableciendo las
relaciones con venezuela pero el tema de
fondo es que pasa con la violación de
derechos humanos en venezuela qué pasa
con la forma como ha venido
cortando el poder de nicolas más dura en
venezuela y con la cantidad de venezuela
que hoy en día están huyendo de
venezuela fruto o producto precisamente
de todos esos abusos de poder que ha
cometido nicolás maduró entonces
reconocer un régimen dictatorial como lo
está haciendo en este momento el
gobierno colombiano es lo que genera
temor no solamente por lo que pueda
suceder en colombia sino precisamente
porque es de alguna manera validar todas
estas acciones que este que viene
haciendo nicolás madura en su país para
con los venezolanos entonces ahí es
donde se prenden las alarmas y con eso
es como lo que no estamos de acuerdo con
que se esté validan se están validando a
todas esas acciones de nicor alba maduro
a sabiendas de que es un dictador y que
le están dando daño al pueblo venezolano
bueno ricardo pero es que incluso eeuu
ha tenido acercamientos recientes con el
gobierno venezolano es decir podría
plantearse que para la región habría una
cambio de enfoque y una manera distinta
de manejar la situación con venezuela a
cómo se había venido manejando hasta
ahora y en ese sentido maría josé pues
usted cree que había otra opción
diferente
reinstaurar embajadores a retomar los
contactos con nicolás maduro y pues a
este destino que está llegando a gustavo
petro que es la reapertura de fronteras
pues mira yo precisamente te iba a decir
eso eeuu a ella ha avanzado en hacer 500
con venezuela precisamente en términos
de poder no solamente en términos de
exhibir y de exigibilidad a los derechos
de la oposición venezolana por supuesto
pero pero hay acercamientos lo cierto es
que con wide o no y vamos a solucionar
el problema amiga migratorio y el
problema de atención a los venezolanos
en colombia ni al flujo migratorio ya
que colombia fuera un país de tránsito
de a todas las situaciones absolutamente
complejas que se nos han presentado con
venezuela definitivamente allí no lo
íbamos a poder solucionar y por lo tanto
después de todos estos años después de
ver que nada de lo que se intentó hacer
funcionó recordemos que el presidente
iván duque dijo
que iba muy pronto a ver cómo caía
maduro y salió duque de la presidencia y
maduro sigue en la presidencia por
supuesto que eso nos tienen que generar
reflexiones en términos desde
digamos de
garantizar y que por supuesto en
venezuela en venezuela se tengan
garantizando los procesos democráticos y
sobre todo los derechos de la oposición
pero aquí estamos hablando de la vida de
la gente y estamos hablando de una
crisis humanitaria sin presidente
presentes en el continente estamos
hablando de que colombia no solamente
atiende una población migrante y
venezolana por millones sino que además
es un país de tránsito y eso son temas
que no tienen espera si nosotros estamos
hablando de solucionar un tema
migratorio acá por supuesto tiene que
ser atendido de garantizar a la
población venezolana en colombia'
derechos sociales pero por supuesto de
garantizar que puedan haber los mínimos
diálogos
y diplomáticos para poder solucionar
cosas que nos podían ser solucionadas
hasta este momento entonces pues yo la
verdad no veo que le vaya a salir mal
creo que por el contrario eeuu nos da un
ejemplo de cómo avanzar en esas
relaciones
diplomáticas y lo que se requiere es
darle solución a una crisis humanitaria
sin precedentes y eso por supuesto nos
lleva a dialogar con
quien está al frente hoy estemos o no de
acuerdo
independientemente de la catalogación
que tengamos frente a su gobierno el
tema de millones de seres humanos que
viven hoy en unas condiciones realmente
de miseria que además cuando atraviesan
la frontera están expuestos a las mafias
a un país en guerra que es el país
colombiano nosotros tampoco podemos dar
muchísimas lecciones de derechos humanos
realmente aquí en colombia la situación
también es difícil es compleja y por lo
tanto lo que tenemos que hacer es
avanzar para qué
se puede a solucionar un problema que
nos ha afectado durante muchísimos años
y que colombia requiere darle una
solución inmediata muy bien y riccardo
para que podamos continuar avanzando en
los temas pues uno de los asuntos que
preocupan en las fronteras es
precisamente la presencia de grupos
armados de grupos ilegales que están
delinquiendo al lado y lado de la
frontera y de ahí quisiera pasar
riccardo a preguntarle por esta apuesta
que hace gustavo petro por la paz total
se la jugó completamente en su primer
mes de gobierno y muchas de sus
decisiones giraron alrededor de ese tema
entonces gustavo petro está ya en
contacto con lln y ha dicho también que
con otros grupos ilegales que quisieran
eventualmente acogerse a esa paz total
después de la experiencia de los
gobiernos anteriores y de un manejo en
el que se decidieron cancelar o
suspender los los diálogos con lln que
no se vieron muchos avances en usted
porque cree que fue eso y cree que este
este acercamiento entre gustavo petro
podría traer algo positivo
bueno yo creo que el la apuesta que hace
gustavo petro hablando de la paz total
pues es más un tema del lenguaje que un
tema que realmente se da en la práctica
llevamos un mes y llevamos 14 masacres
en colombia en estos 30 días del
gobierno del presidente gustavo petro en
los momentos 30 días de iván duque y la
situación de de lo que tiene que ver con
este este tipo de
hechos eran 4 versus 14 eso nos lleva a
ver que cuál es la paz total si es que
aquí lo que tenemos son unos grupos al
margen de la ley empoderados que se
sienten con el derecho de hablarle como
se dice coloquialmente durito al
presidente de la república porque
sienten que ellos van a tener la
posibilidad para que tengamos otra es un
presidente que quiera vender en la
posibilidad de obtener galardones en
materia de paso ser reconocido como un
presidente que está apostándole a la paz
que tiene que callarse y aguantar todo
lo que los grupos ilegales hoy por hoy
me preocupa mucho que se estén y
desmoralizando nuestras fuerzas armadas
que nuestras fuerzas armadas vean en el
comandante en jefe que es el presidente
de la república una persona que no
respalda las fuerzas armadas que no
respalda las fuerzas militares y que por
el contrario está siendo muy
complaciente con esos grupos al margen
de la ley
efe/ricardo ya que está hablando de eso
disculpe que lo interrumpa usted cree
que fue un error ese gran sacudón que se
dio a las fuerzas armadas la salida de
generales de con experiencia el cambio
de enfoque para buscar que pues no se
violen los derechos humanos que cree que
hubo error ahí en esa decisión
lo que pasa es que estamos mezclando
temas si hay personas que han violado
derechos humanos tienen que salir si hay
personas que han cometido delitos tienen
que ser judicial izadas pero
estigmatizar a las fuerzas armadas y
simplemente hacen una barrida como la
que se hizo simplemente parece más una
retaliación de alguien que hoy en día
está al frente de las mismas que
finalmente lo que se estaba esperando
por parte de las fuerzas armadas que era
el respaldo de su presidente una fuerza
de armas que le han apostado a la
institucionalidad que son que fueron las
víctimas de muchos de los hechos que
sucedidos por el bloque cuando hubo gran
paro nacional
fueron nuestros policías los que le
hicieron el frente al paro nacional
fueron muchos de ellos los que
terminaron pues siendo atacados siendo
siendo las víctimas de todo lo que
ocurrió en esas en esos días del paro y
que hoy en día sencillamente no sienten
el respaldo del presidente de la
republica sienten que un gran número de
generales fueron simplemente borrados en
una carrera que no duran y uno ni dos ni
tres años sino que es una carrera de
toda la vida y que terminaron terminados
con el presidente de la republica
simplemente colgando los uniformes y que
pues que en ese orden de ideas pues
obviamente que es el presidente la
recurrió a quien toma las decisiones de
quienes los rodean es las obras armadas
pero ese mensaje no fue un mensaje
positivo y obviamente que tiene
moralizada gran parte de la tropa en
nuestro país esto dice usted sumado a
los contactos con el ln y otros grupos
armados de maria jose ahora quisiera
pasar a ustedes para pedirle su opinión
pues mira no yo quisiera empezar por
donde empezó mi colega ricardo ferro y
la diferencia frente a las masacres el
número de masacres con lo que estaba
sucediendo nada en el mandato de bando
que era una en el momento en el que iván
duque asume la presidencia de la
república nosotros veníamos con un
hospital militar que tenía sus camas
vacías es decir un hospital
absolutamente vacío quiere decir que
nosotros no estábamos en un momento de
confrontación lo que sucede hoy es que
precisamente nosotros venimos o más bien
haya un acumulado del no haber hecho
absolutamente nada en relación con la
paz en este país o más bien no vamos a
decir absolutamente nada pero por lo
menos 2000 lo mínimo que había que hacer
y por lo tanto nosotros habíamos
retornado unas cifras de violencia
que no se veían desde antes de la firma
de los acuerdos de paz y ese es el saldo
que nos dejen al duque si nosotros
miramos el gobierno hindú que estamos
hablando de que en esos primeros 30 días
habían 32 líderes sociales asesinados sí
y por supuesto que lo que nosotros
estamos enviando es un mensaje al país
yo quisiera retomar aquí las palabras
del padre vicente room
quien estaba al frente de la comisión de
la verdad y así a una pregunta que a mí
me parece absolutamente valiosa y es
donde estaban la academia donde estaban
los medios de comunicación donde estaba
la sociedad colombiana y por supuesto
donde estaba el estado mientras en los
años más duros del conflicto armado
colombiano sucedían las tragedias y todo
el mundo miraba hacia otro lado pues
precisamente clico se nos presenta es
una oportunidad la oportunidad de no
mirar hacia otro lado la oportunidad de
entregarle la posibilidad de la paz a
colombia y la paz no es una imposición
la paz es una construcción la paz
requiere diálogo se requiere
concertación y sobre todo voluntad
política lo que nosotros no hemos tenido
es precisamente voluntad política y
colombiana
de la guerra o lo que haya andado los
caminos de la vivencia y lo que
colombiano han dado son los caminos de
la paz y yo creo que estamos a tiempo de
empezar a andar los caminos de la paz de
presupuesto entregarle a las juventudes
un país completamente diferentes y para
eso se barre que el tiempo se va a
requerir paciencia no estamos hablando
entre angelitos estamos hablando por
supuesto con estructuras armadas aquí no
se trata de combatir a dos o tres
delincuentes
estamos hablando de estructuras armadas
organizadas en nuestro país con las que
por supuesto se tiene que dialogar la
vida de la guerra nos ha llevado a
ningún dado la vida de la la vía de la
paz por supuesto es muchísimo más
efectiva pero requieren tiempo no es
inmediato pero tiene a largo plazo unos
efectos completamente diferentes a los
efectos que tiene continuar en ciclos de
vivencia donde absolutamente
degradados y donde ella tiene hay un
costo en vidas humanas enorme ese es el
destino que luche de colombia por
supuesto que yo puedo reconocer que los
miembros de la fuerza pública
o reconocer que los miembros de la
fuerza pública
tuvieron que sufrir
digamos durante ese parón nacional y
agresiones etcétera pero no nos podemos
olvidar bajo ninguna circunstancia que
también la sociedad colombiana ha tenido
que sufrir hoy justo hace un año hace
dos años de 9 y el 10 de septiembre en
bogotá eran asesinados por parte de la
policía 13 jóvenes y ni hablemos de lo
que sucedió con unas prácticas que
veníamos denunciando yo como
representante a la cámara en sendos
debates de control político y por
supuesto también en audiencias públicas
denuncie que estas prácticas están
volviendo sistemáticas al interior de la
institución y mira lo que sucedió un año
después de nueve días de septiembre unos
meses después en el paro nacional no
solamente los policías vivieron
agresiones y unas situaciones
absolutamente complejas sino que la
ciudadanía también se vio agrediendo es
aquí tenemos que hacer un acto un acto
en el camino hay algo que decía mi padre
los momentos en los que firmaba la paz y
es que teníamos que seguir los caminos
de la rectificación aquí todo el mundo
tiene que rectificar y rectificar
implica que todo el mundo se mira hacia
adentro y mira si puede darle al país un
camino diferente por supuesto que estoy
completamente comprometida con la paz
total por supuesto entiendo que va a
requerir tiempos ya los concertación es
que no va a ser fácil pero que si las
cosas también bien y estoy convencida de
que van a salir bien vamos a poder
entregarle a colombia no de estilo
diferente esperemos que así sea y sobre
todo esperamos que la oposición se sume
ese camino que podamos tener
conversaciones serias constructivas
mirando hacia adelante con sectores de
la oposición que seguramente piensan
distinto
a nosotros pero que con los cuales
tenemos algo en común y es la
posibilidad de soñar los que ofrecía la
colombia un país diferentes muy bien
ricardo usted tiene alguna réplica que
hacer sobre eso porque las discusiones
que se han dado sobre la aplicación de
los acuerdos de paz han sido muy amplios
en los últimos cuatro años y bueno hoy
todavía son un centro de conversación
dentro del gobierno de gustavo petro
más que réplica me parece fabuloso que
desde voces como la de maría josé
pizarro y otras voces que hoy en día
están en el gobierno pues que hoy en día
se esté hablando de que no teníamos una
verdadera paz que lo que nos había
vendido en colombia juan manuel santos
era humo porque no es lo mismo un
proceso de desmovilización de un grupo
guerrillero como fue el proceso de
movilización de las farc que se vivió en
el gobierno juan manuel santos con lo
que en la paz con lo que es la
consolidación de la paz lo que hoy en
día estamos viendo en colombia es que no
hay paz que bien que se movilizó un
grupo guerrillero que hay ahí tenemos
serias diferencias sobre todo lo que
entregó el estado colombiano a cambio de
una desmovilización de algunos de ese
grupo guerrillero porque finalmente lo
que moore fue que no se desmovilizaron
todos los del grupo guerrillero que se
le entregaron 10 curules y el 20 por
ciento de quienes residen en las cruces
volvieron otra vez de delinquir están
involucrados en temas de narcotráfico al
tema de
las mismas prácticas de extorsión de
atentados terroristas en fin todo lo que
vivía antes de todas esas prebendas que
tuvieron con ocasión del proceso de
movilización de juan manuel santos
comparto plenamente ese deseo por la paz
total es un deseo que tenemos todos los
colombianos ojalá y lo podamos lograr
pero para que haya paz total hay unos
temas que son fundamentales en marjah o
se hablaba de la comisión de la verdad
la comisión de la verdad
desafortunadamente tiene un sesgo
ideológico un sesgo político un sesgo
que lepe que no le permite realmente
abordar el tema de la verdad como lo
necesitamos todos los colombianos si
queremos realmente alcanzar la paz
entonces necesitamos que haya una verdad
perdóname la redundancia una verdad
verdadera en colombia si queremos que
haya paz necesitamos que nos podamos
reconciliar y para eso es fundamental
que dejemos de un lado los sesgos
ideológicos el quién y que mamé nos
preocupemos por el que mientras estemos
más preocupados por el quién dice él
quien es y a quién vamos a jugar y a
quien no en ese momento vamos a no vamos
a poder llegar a lograr lo que necesita
el pueblo colombiano que es la paz total
y en eso lo que tenemos que
comprometernos todos los que queramos
realmente aportar un granito de arena a
esta ya las próximas generaciones en
nuestro país que eso ya queríamos que
hagamos leche que al tema de paz y
podamos y que podamos avanzar en otros
temas que son necesarios avanzar como
sociedad en colombia
una pregunta para los dos hijos sí sí sí
sí yo solamente quería digamos tal vez
hacer una apreciación en relación con
intervención
digamos por supuesto que nosotros no
recibimos después del mandato de juan
manuel santos un país 100% de la paz
recibimos un país caminando hacia la paz
y yo creo que esto es importante
reconocerlo y es importante comprender
la paz vuelvo y repito es un proceso de
construcción
la tragedia fue que durante estos cuatro
años no solamente no avanzamos sino que
en muchos casos retrocedimos en algunos
casos nos estuvimos exactamente igual
nosotros hoy no podemos decir y no
podemos afirmar porque sería
profundamente irresponsable que quienes
están hoy y han estado cuatro años antes
que nosotros en el congreso de la
república y son desmovilizados
de las farc y que hoy hacen parte del
partido comunes han continuado eligiendo
eso no es así eso no es así nosotros
tenemos
mayoritariamente una población de
reincorporados que se ha mantenido en la
paz por supuesto que hay un grupo de
gente que regreso a las armas y por
supuesto y por supuesto eso ya implica
un traspié inmenso a la paz si tenemos
que rectificar el camino yo coincido con
él con mi colega perdón
ricardo pero por supuesto que coincido
contigo colega
necesario que nosotros miremos que aquí
no se trata de sesgos ideológicos por
supuesto que nosotros también como
sectores políticos tenemos que
rectificar cómo tienen que rectificar
toda la sociedad colombiana para que la
paz sea posible y yo sé leo como tú
celebras el hecho de que podamos empezar
a andar ese camino lo primero que
tenemos que empezar a comprender es que
podemos dirimir nuestros conflictos
nuestras diferencias de una manera
diferente que podemos entender que jamás
vamos a pensar igual no vamos a pensar
igual pero que nuestro nuestras
diferencias en nuestro pensamiento de
nuestra ideología no tiene que
traducirse en una guerra sin cuartel en
los territorios por supuesto que eso
tiene que comprender sé que la forma de
dirimir los conflictos por la tierra los
conflictos sociales los los conflictos
ambientales no es matando a la gente que
la forma de dirimir los conflictos
políticos no es matando a la
que la sociedad colombiana nos merece
ese destino por supuesto tendremos que
hacer enormes esfuerzos toda el mundo en
la sociedad colombiana periodistas
empresarios la ciudadanía políticos
etcétera para lograr por supuesto seguir
en nuestro en nuestro en nuestro empeño
por la paz pero hoy podemos celebrar que
hay voluntad política que es lo mínimo
que
debería hacer en un gobierno voluntad
política para salir de los abismos de la
guerra y encaminarnos por los horizontes
de las
ricardo y maría josé una de las primeras
actividades que realizó gustavo petro
durante este mes que acaba de cumplir
fue una reunión con funcionarios
antidrogas que viajaron desde washington
estuvieron en bogotá se plantearon
varias cosas entre ellas eeuu admite que
pudo haberlo hecho mejor en todos estos
años en la lucha contra las drogas y
esto implica que podrían hacerse cambios
en la manera en que se combaten los
estupefacientes y las sustancias
ilegales y aquí va mi pregunta para los
dos es obsoleta el día de hoy la lucha
contra las drogas como la conocemos hoy
empiezo con ricardo
y bueno hay que hay que reconducir el
camino lo que tiene que ver con la lucha
contra la droga pero eso no significa
que no sigamos luchando contra la droga
nosotros no podemos darnos por vencidos
no sacarían al estado colombiano
diciendo bueno y ahora
después de una lucha de
décadas de 3 4 ó 5 décadas ahora en todo
lo que vamos a hacer es que vamos a
darle la razón a los narcotraficantes y
vamos a legalizar la droga no ese para
mí no es el camino y ahí se equivocaría
el gobierno colombiano en tratar de
legalizar la droga o en buscar que ese
sea el camino entre otras razones porque
colombia no puede pensar que esa es una
decisión que tiene que tomar un estado
de manera aislada como está pensando el
mundo el mundo sigue luchando contra las
drogas y el mundo quiere que acabar con
el flagelo de las drogas defender a sus
jóvenes lastimosamente que decirlo
defender a sus niños porque muchos de
los niños en el mundo hoy en día están
conociendo la droga desde cuando son
niños ya entrando en el mundo de la
droga entonces esa pelea que está dando
el mundo colombiano puede ser el que
vaya en el camino contrario más aún
cuando colombia es un país productor de
droga queremos que combatir la droga si
hay hay que reconducir el camino de
pronto hay que
buscar otras fórmulas para poder
contrarrestar los cultivos ilícitos pero
tenemos que seguir atacando los cultivos
ilícitos tenemos que seguir defendiendo
en nuestros parques nacionales en sus
parques naturales nuestro territorio
para que no tengamos edad cifra
alarmante de más de doscientas mil
hectáreas de coca como hoy en día la
tiene colombia y para eso hay que
combatirlo hoy en día ya no tenemos que
hablar de los mismos fungicidas o
herbicidas que hablábamos hace algunos
años y que obviamente afectan el medio
ambiente afecta a la vida como tal hay
unos hay unos servicios unos fungicidas
que pueden funcionar y que no son y que
simplemente atacan como tal las matas de
coca y perdón que entrase a ese nivel de
minucia pero lo que no podemos dejar de
hacer es dejar de combatir los cultivos
ilícitos y en eso nosotros como
colombianos esperamos que el presidente
interprete la voluntad del pueblo
colombiano e interprete la voluntad de
la comunidad internacional la voluntad
del mundo el mundo tiene que ir es hacia
acabar las drogas no legalizar este esta
esta estas drogas que tanto daño le
hacen vuelvo y repito a nuestros jóvenes
ya nuestros niños gracias ricardo maría
josé
bueno yo quería empezar por donde
termina
mi colega ricardo ferro y es
precisamente que esta es una discusión a
nivel mundial no es la lucha contra las
drogas no es una responsabilidad única y
exclusivamente de colombia la lucha
contra las drogas es una discusión
obligatoria a nivel continental y
obligatoria a nivel mundial por supuesto
que la lucha contra las drogas hasta ha
fracasado sino no tendríamos en
colombia' cultivos de droga en expansión
no seríamos el país el mayor productor
de coca del mundo por supuesto no
tendríamos el conflicto afgano por
ejemplo
precisamente derivado de otras drogas
que no se producen en colombia se
producen allí pero que vivió en
conflictos absolutamente difíciles y por
supuesto para la sociedad es una
tragedia humana por supuesto que eso
requiere profundas reflexiones y
requiere una discusión a nivel global ya
nivel continental colombia es un país
productor pero el resto de países de
américa latina muchos de ellos son
países de tránsito y quien es real y
quienes además sufren también el flagelo
como lo sufre colombia son los los
consumidores cuantos jóvenes no mueren
al año por el consumo de drogas en
países como eeuu europa canadá etcétera
y cuántos colombianos y colombianas no
mueren todos los días precisamente por
precisamente por por las consecuencias
que a nosotros queda en la guerra y nos
queda el conflicto y nos quedan
situaciones absolutamente trágicas
porque no ha existido a nivel nacional
una lucha realmente efectiva en contra
de las drogas por supuesto yo soy de las
que piensa que la decisión del
presidente gustavo petro de él de
finalizar de acabar con la erradicación
forzada es un buen camino que hay
mecanismos de concertación que lo que
nos demuestran las cifras es que la
erradicación forzosa y la fumigación con
glifosato no ha tenido éxito en nuestro
país y que por supuesto lo que se
requiere es avanzar en otras rutas rutas
que han sido dialogadas consensuadas y
frente a las cuales puede que nos
demoramos un poco más pero vamos a tener
resultados positivos a largo plazo
es
creo que las decisiones de gustavo petro
no solamente lo dijo en campaña y está
siendo consecuente con lo que dijo en
campaña sino que además se está poniendo
por delante de cualquier otra
consideración la vida de los colombianos
y de las colombianas que estamos
cansados de vivir inmersos en ciclos de
violencia ciclos de violencia que son
precisamente muchas veces alimentados
por la gasolina de la droga pero que la
lucha como se nos ha planteado y no lo
han demostrado estos últimos 30-40 años
no a no permitir y no ha dado resultados
positivos colombia tiene que enmarcarse
y tiene que plantear la discusión a
nivel continental y tiene que plantear
la discusión a nivel global porque la
responsabilidad no le puede quedar
solamente a colombia y en lo interno por
supuesto continuar luchando
contra el narcotráfico pero por supuesto
poner por delante la vida de campesinos
y de campesinas de personas en los
territorios de jóvenes en nuestro país
no puede seguir aumentando el consumo
interno y eso implica tomar decisiones
de fondo pero por supuesto hay unos
principios básicos de respeto a los
derechos humanos que tienen que
prevalecer
bueno de todas maneras un mes es muy
poco tiempo como decía yo al principio
de este programa para hacer una
evaluación de lo que es o de lo que
podría llegar a ser el gobierno de
gustavo petro aquí simplemente estamos
viendo los trazados que se están
haciendo y ya llegando al final del
programa con nuestros invitados quisiera
entrar un poco más en el terreno
económico porque ha sido una discusión
que se ha dado todos los días en medios
nacionales y es la entrada de una nueva
reforma tributaria está ya será la
última respuesta así que les pido que
traten de ser muy concretos en sus ideas
mientras que la reforma tributaria en el
gobierno de llevando que produjo un
levantamiento social sin precedentes en
colombia ahora el gobierno de gustavo
petro intenta traer una nueva reforma
tributaria que genera otro tipo de
preocupaciones entonces para sus
opositores se preocupa que esa reforma
de se incentive la inversión extranjera
mientras que busca impulsar el gasto
social que ha sido un gran enfoque
prometido en campaña por gustavo petro y
el otro que preocupa a la oposición es
si servirá efectivamente para reducir el
déficit de presupuestario entonces
ricardo aquí el micrófono abierto para
que ustedes expresen esas preocupaciones
angela bueno la preocupación fundamental
en lo que tiene que ver con la reforma
tributaria es que
no se le puede decir mentiras a los
colombianos
cualquier aumento de impuestos va a
afectar al pueblo colombiano el
principio en materia impositiva es que
siempre el impuesto se traslada para el
consumidor final eso no lo podemos
desconocer cuando alguien dice no es que
estos impuestos es que cuando le cobran
en el iva simplemente le están cobrando
al que lo va a comprar el producto en
cambio cuando le suben el impuesto al
empresario es que hay que darle como he
escuchado algunos que me parece que es
una irresponsabilidad seguir polarizando
el país es que hay que darle duro a los
ricos hay que darle duro a los
empresarios hay que ponerlos a pagar más
hombre esa es una falacia esa es una
mentira ese impuesto que se le está
poniendo al empresario pues el
empresario lo va a terminar trasladando
y lo terminan creando para quien pues
para el consumidor final es tiempo de
ese impuesto que los tranques se le está
poniendo al empresario oa la empresa
puede terminar en que haya desempleo
en que al empresario le toque
prescindir de algunos de sus empleados
es en ese impuesto que se está poniendo
hoy en día obviamente afecta la economía
y estaba en un momento en el cual
estamos como en el rebote después de lo
que sucedió con el hobbit después de
todas las dificultades económicas que
vivimos por contra la pandemia en
colombia y en el mundo estamos en un
punto de rebote en el cual la economía
en colombia se ha comportado bien y en
este primer semestre tuvimos unas cifras
alentadoras para la sociedad colombiana
de tenerlo ahí disculpe pero nos queda
un minuto de programa y quisiera
escuchar también a varios no siempre
no no no yo voy a ser muy breve
yo quisiera recordar que iniciando el
gobierno de bandung lo que hubo fue un
anuncio que se materializó y fue
precisamente una reducción de la carga
tributaria a las grandes empresas y que
se tradujo en toda una serie de regalos
tributarios que en últimas sumaban 10
millones de pesos anuales firmo tantos
regalos tributarios que estamos hablando
de 59 billones al año
imagínate tú es la tragedia nosotros
aquí no estamos hablando de golpear las
pequeñas y medianas empleo empresas que
por supuesto son las que más empleos
producen en nuestro país estamos
hablando de casi el 70% del empleo en
colombia y del 40 por ciento del
producto interno bruto sino que estamos
hablando
además
que no pueden tener la misma carga
tributaria que tienen las grandes
empresas en nuestro país por supuesto
que estamos hablando de que exista un
mínimo de justicia tributaria si a veces
incómodo de moleste tanto el término de
justicia justicia tributaria así por
supuesto de manera que aquellos que más
tienen en el 98 por ciento población
pues de alguna manera pueda ejercer la
solidaridad así lo dijo el presidente
gustavo petro en su discurso de posición
con una población
absolutamente golpeada no solamente
después de la pandemia sino siendo el
segundo país más desigual del mundo aquí
se trata un poco de equilibrar las
cargas y por supuesto que esa es una
reforma tributaria progresiva pero lo
que lo que buscamos es poder garantizar
todos estos derechos sociales por los
que votó la sociedad colombiana así que
por mi parte estaremos atentos por
supuesto a remitir las recomendaciones
que escuchamos de las organizaciones
sociales para mejorar la reforma
tributaria pero la reforma tributaria
hoy debe seguir porque por de entrada
debemos echar un poco hacia atrás
aquellas decisiones que no fueron
favorables para la sociedad colombiana y
que han supuesto un retroceso enorme en
términos sociales para la gente gracias
a bueno muchísimas gracias maría josé
pizarro ricardo ferro aquí damos por
concluido el debate con muchos temas por
fuera y mucho tiempo también para
continuar haciendo esta evaluación
gracias a ustedes ya nuestros
televidentes sigan en france24
[Música]